will digital activists supporting Iran's
wave of women-led protests have hacked a
state television live news broadcast
superimposing flames on the face of
supreme leader Ayatollah Ali Harmony the
blood of our youth is on your hands
reads a message on screen
meantime video shared on social media
also appears to show female students
chanting raisi get lost during a visit
to the university to a university by the
country's president Ibraham rayis it
follows four weeks of protest after the
death of 22 year old Masa amini while
she was in the custody of Iran's
morality police
and the regime in Tehran accuses
foreigners of inciting the protests and
last week announced that it had arrested
nine European Nationals while their
culpability may be in question it's
clear that people outside Iran are
outraged by the Islamic Republic's
treatment of women over the weekend
thousands of them took to the streets
around the world
freedom for Iran is what these
protesters in London are chanting for
they are here to show support for
Iranians standing up against their
leadership some are leaving Iran's
pre-1979 flag from before the Revolution
that brought islamists to power
foreign
four years this regime Islamic regime
they are torturing executing prisoning
people without any reason I at the
moment they are killing people on the
streets just because they are the most
have a demonstration
in Italy people gathered outside the
Iranian Embassy in solidarity with
Iranian women
it is necessary to stand with the
Iranian people and with Iranian women
because we know they're victims of a
criminal system that humiliates women
and tortures them Iranian women face
prison every day for these
demonstrations
mahasa amini is also remembered here in
Chile her death in the custody of Iran's
morality police triggered nation-wide
protests women here cut their hair to
show resistance to the strict dress code
in the Islamic Republic that requires
women to cover their heads
I cut my hair for maximini who was
murdered
murdered besides many other women have
also been killed in Iran so I cut my
hair in solidarity with them
people here say they will continue to
support Iranian protesters in their
struggle